Now let's start with performance
metrics for a classification problem.
In this lesson, we focus on describing metrics
for evaluating binary classification problems,
for example predicting whether patients
would develop heart failure or not.
These metrics can be generalized to the setting
with multiple classes as well. But in this lesson,
we'll focus on the binary setting. There are
many evaluation metrics for classification model.
Next, we'll illustrate how they're all
connected. To depending on the prediction
and the Ground Truth value, we have four different
possible outcomes. True Positive, False Positive,
False Negative and True Negative. Next, we explain
their definition and relationship to each other.
So, the output of a binary predictive
model, can be either Positive or Negative.
Here, you can see a zoom in version of this. To
differentiate with the Ground Truth value, we call
this Prediction Outcome Positive, and Prediction
Outcome Negative. Similarly, we have the Ground
Truth value can be either Positive and Negative.
Again, to differentiate with the prediction value,
we call this Condition Positive and Condition
Negative. If the Prediction Outcome is positive,
and the Ground Truth's value is also positive,
then we call this, True Positive. However,
if the Prediction Outcome is positive, but
the Ground Truth condition is negative,
then we call this False Positive, or Type I error.
Conversely, if the Prediction Outcome is negative,
and the Ground Truth Condition is positive,
we call this False Negative, or Type II error.
Finally, a True Negative occur, when Prediction
Outcome and Ground Truth Condition are both
Negative. In fact, this 2x2 matrix is called
a Confusion Matrix, or a Contingency table.
Now, we understand all
the definitions of this basic matrix. Let's
look at the relationship among this matrix.
First, each row and column of this matrix sum
up to the marginal. For example, True Positive
plus False Positive equals Prediction Outcome
Positive. And the True Positive plus the False
Negative equals the Condition Positive. And the
Total Population equals the Prediction Outcome
Positive plus Prediction Outcome Negative. Or
Condition Positive plus Condition Negative.